let's try e4 here
ok
petrov where I Lopez philidor Cochran's
gambit caucus gambit it's official d5
Bishop b3 hmm Black is Chu enough time
let's see
already so what do you do against the
cochrane gambit d5 bishop e6 my opponent
has typed darn it I don't know this ah
let's pull the King a little bit closer
come on out don't be scared ah ok what
about d4 castle mmm Castle time d for
time Knight c3 time f4 time none of the
above
this can't be bad can it
this can't be bad no no no no this is
this is the move this is the move a
giant pond center is running scared
scaredy cat it's kind of it's kind of
what you have to do though I mean that's
where I have compensation give up the
minor piece the King's gonna be a little
bit scared scaredy cat line King f7
running for the hills fleeing he's
fleeing now that night should I pin him
this like this I might want to queenside
castle house I might not want to do that
h4 h5 there's some appeal to that I
think whoo I can get pretty juicy right
there what about Queen f3 with pawn push
exploiting the pin getting at b7 yeah
like this Queen f3 get my bishop out
even and then queenside castle and i
think everything is lovely then I maybe
there still is this h4 h5 possibility
here we go
I have my eggs all in one basket here so
it's do or die with this type of
imbalance hmm
let's play here I still have this e5
idea with then follow-up discovered
check possibilities queenside castle
here we go throw my other rook on e 1
it's threatened again and now it cannot
be prevented but wait a second which
rook to play to e 1 I think it's the
deer up that's better because I still I
just um I think of I'm still thinking of
this h4 h5 idea as soon as I throw a
rope here the King I think has to go
back probably the g8 otherwise this pond
advance comes in successfully the night
ever moves then there's eventual Bishop
g5 discovered check Queen dead or minor
piece at least wait but why not just
this right away whoo bond push takes
takes Knight takes bishop takes rook
here Queen check ah that's a pain
and is one that don't want to deal with
is it
now I'm abandoned it with this last move
I'm definitely abandoning any h4 h5 idea
and now black is beat z5 vote was going
to be a killer I at the very least get
back a minor piece now night Esther run
and now Bishop g5 is happening not
enough time to get fully developed at
this point c6 I guess was aimed at
defending it was defending against an
eventual Queen B 7 but yeah the King
position is the one that was the most
important to address first at least so
time should not be an issue what is the
best resistance black can be putting up
here i have the i also have the
possibility of just capturing her excuse
me just playing e 6 and grabbing the
night on d7 and having a past on like
right now ooh actually there's rook
takes Knight I have several good choices
here Bishop G Pawnee immediately rook
takes Knight fought by pawn push Bishop
check
this is best i think just with the
eventual capture i'm on the queen and
night both files opened up now Queens
hit twice it's almost like a double I
just gonna say double check but like a
double attack on the Queen if she wants
to be saved just like in double check
the king must always move if the Queen's
in a double attack she's usually going
to have to move and now things are just
falling here so my bishop does have
pressure on it playing here there's got
to be May happening soon
so this is trouble no good solution
right the cochrane gambit out of the
Petrov Petroff is something we could see
in the World Championship match but I
can assure you there will be no Cochran
gambit I would be very surprised if we
saw that imagine that all right this is
ending with the pond mate f7 all right
good game chamiya let's back up I do
have if you are wondering Cochran's
gambit I'm trying to see I'm going to a
link a video live blitz a video that I
posted to my youtube channel out of the
Cochran's gambit if you're looking for
some more insight because i'm not doing
I never really do anything thorough here
after the blitz games but here's a video
I'm linking it in the chat out of this
opening so just as some additional
reference could maybe review that if
it's of interest to you so Petrov
Cochran's gambit I do in that video
reference d5 giving back the pond with
the follow-up Bishop d6 rook to e8 and
then tuck that King away get castled
artificially this is a little bit scary
i think at the very least when it does
get to this point as soon as this rook
is played you have to get out of this
you have to get off of the f file you
have to try king g8 and then be prepared
to retreat with your night after i get
this move in successfully i think i
don't know i think that there might not
even be a great continuation for you
because if you're doing this you're
brooke is you're playing down a rock and
I
have everything mobilized so it's pretty
scary here I think d5 is something to
look into maybe even just bring your
king back maybe i'm not i'm not sure but
at that later stage I'm definitely sure
that you have to get off of the F file
with your king so my earliest suggestion
is to play around with the d5 move
before or in response to this considered
e5 pawn takes bishop d6 and you'll get
you'll get your rook and King
coordinated I believe now if if I'm a
bit more stubborn after d5 I could just
be backing up and not taking and at
which point you could maybe then play
see 6 to just reinforce your d5 pawn but
anyhow consider d5 at this at this
moment here can't be hundred percent
sure that it's best but it's another way
to approach the bishop check mo